in this country do you take any
responsibility or policies i think our
policies help not hurt
president biden taking zero
responsibility for record high inflation
and actually claims he's helping
americans
somebody at the white house forgot to
tell biden the facts and the polls say
otherwise americans are getting crushed
by an avalanche of economic disasters
gas prices just hit another record high
today more americans are struggling to
make ends meet and parents can't even
find baby formula
the president making it clear he has no
plan to fix all the problems and instead
he's blaming the usual suspects
there are two
leading causes of inflation we're seeing
today
the first cause of inflation is a once
in a century pandemic a second cause mr
putin's war in ukraine
you saw we saw in march that 60 percent
of inflation that month was due to price
increases at the pump
biden also hammering this phantom ultra
maga agenda the gop hasn't even signed
on to while pushing a talking point the
washington post is called a lie
senator rick scott wisconsin a member of
the senate republican leadership laid it
all out the ultra maga
plan
put forward by congressional republicans
to raise taxes on working families
lower the income of american workers i
never expected
the
ultra
mega republicans
who seem to control the republican party
now
to have been able to control the
republican party
i want to listen to what dana has to say
about ultra maga but first let's listen
to what jen saki had to say about how
this whole phrase came to be
is the president's phrase and the
president
made those comments himself just last
week as you know and i think what has
struck him is how extreme some of the
policies and proposals are that a
certain wing of the republican party
that is taking up too much of the
republican party are are for so to him
adding a little ultra to it give it a
little extra pop
is he giving it a little extra pop i
just i i can't stand it because i feel
like it's you're walking down this aisle
at the convenience store or the cvs and
looking for something that would say
ultra maga and it's gross to me i can't
stand it
out of my head what product i want them
to stop and if that just because she
comes out and says ultra mega 20 times
is not going to make inflation go away
they can also say rick scott 100 000
times that guy is eating alone at the
lunch table basically there's nobody in
the republican party that signed onto
his plan he can have his plan and he has
every right to try to push it but by no
means does the ultra magga group
actually support it that's absurd also
they say that rick scott wants to raise
taxes and that's so extreme they want to
raise taxes why don't they jump on board
the rick scott agenda uh choice versus a
referendum that's exactly what you're
going to hear me say a hundred times as
many times as they say ultra mega i am
going to say that because they know this
from the biden year obama biden years of
2010 and 2014 where they lost seats if
it's a choice between
uh biden or trump that's what the team
wants here that's what the biden team
wants but everybody is dealing with
inflation every single day it's a
referendum on the president that's what
the midterms are about they can try to
make it a choice it's going to be very
difficult last thing if i as a
communications person
was planning on having my boss go out
and give a big speech about lowering gas
prices and i wake up in the morning and
all the headlines are like oh triple h
just said it's the record high gas
prices and you actually come out and you
have built something as a new plan and
you give an entire speech that has
nothing new in it
then you have lost the confidence of the
people who are turning to you hoping
that you will provide them some relief
and they know it is not coming greg
gutfeld
why do you look so important i think
what you're trying to say about ultra
magga is that it's a trojan horse
[Laughter]
exactly what i'm trying i was holding
that in for so long
but no so what's and then you have
senator scott right responding and
senator scott this is like really harsh
it's even harsh by my standards he said
that biden is incapacitated incoherent
he's unwell he's unfit he's confused
he's incapable those are all the words
rick scott used and it's like somebody
threw a can of paint on biden and
nobody's helping him wipe it off it's
like there's no responses to that biden
just responded and said he doesn't rick
scott's not well but it's like nobody is
bothering to defend him because all of
those things could be argued
persuasively and i'm with you about this
maggot phrase i think it shows how
little game they have that no one's
picking it up and they're just laughing
at it it's not definitely not let's go
brandon which was genius because of its
subterfuge and also i mean it's not it's
not visual like crooked hairy cricket
hairy
so anyway it's like a loser who chooses
their own nickname and nobody's picking
it up the problem with joe is that joe
actually looks great in his suit he when
he puts on the bomber jacket and the
aviator glasses he looks like the head
of the airplane flight crew who's gotten
mistaken as the pilot you know he should
be welcoming the passengers and messing
up the kid's hair and giving the little
wings to the little girl he should not
be in the cockpit and that's the problem
the democrats have realized he's in the
cockpit you got to get him out
yeah there's no game with ultra maga and
i don't think if you are mega you're not
like oh ultra mega he got me
janine how do you think this is going to
play i don't think it's going to play at
all and what i want to know is i mean he
says his policies have helped more than
they've hurt i mean where's the
disinformation board when you really
need it i mean you know nothing that he
says is true and this ultra mega plan i
mean besides the fact that ultra is
supposed to like gin it up and tee it up
so you can really hate if you ate mega
you really hate ultra matter you know
but i spoke to several senators and they
said nobody signed on to rick scott's
plan nobody and that means nobody it's
never going to make the floor mitch
mcconnell doesn't like it rick scott's a
junior senator from florida who cares so
joe biden is comparing his plan to
nothing but what makes me crazy about
biden is he says he says we're going to
plan to reduce the uh prescription drug
prices you are we'll do it you've got
the house you've got the senate you've
got the oval when are you going to do
this stuff all he can do is he's just
sharpening the rhetoric toward the
republicans and everybody says but gas
still costs now four or five dollars
depending upon where you live nothing's
changed did you see anything different
in the speech today
besides the sharp partisan attacks
well we're getting into political season
we're heavy into it um i do think this
ultra maga
thing i look i i your views around the
table are all respectable and
understandable but i think it could be
something that sticks if you look at
what happened in ohio j.d vance wins the
primary more than two-thirds of the
republicans voted against j.d manson at
primary rick scott he's the head of the
republican senate campaign committee
he's a junior senator but he's been
tasked with and dana and i both know
that role that that is a role that is
important to republicans winning back
the senate uh this go round if he has a
plan that differs from
mitch mcconnell uh if there were a
democrat that had a different plan than
biden we would be talking about it
negatively rightly so and i'd be
criticizing this guy has a different
plan than mitch mcconnell who i think is
as effective a minority leader and
arguably a majority leader as we've seen
look we need to be honest the pandemic
and the war have
have increased fuel and energy prices i
would have respected the president's
message even more it'd been more
credible if he said look we're going to
increase energy production here at home
all in natural gas production have to be
upped here as we think about how we uh
going forward address these challenges
and eventually get to a green energy
platform in the country but until then
we've got to produce more fossil fuels
and last we ought to raise taxes on
billionaires anybody that's not for that
uh ought to be ashamed of themselves if
i were i'd be happy to pay more taxes we
ought to raise the carried interest tax
democrats this is one thing i agree with
you about we've had the majorities for a
while democrats have had the majorities
in the house senate obama had it and now
biden and they've yet to raise taxes on
they've yet to raise the carried
interest tax that's the tax that allows
a group of investors who are investing
other people's money to enjoy a
different tax when they make money when
i make money i pay regular taxes
democrats raise that one first but i got
to tell you i'm not at all mad about
this ultra mega thing it might stick and
if you think that's going to stick it
might and if it doesn't stick to
something that's
people will just say great i'm ultra
maggots
and then what are they going to call the
what's the next
level
they want to try
they want to try to pull up they're
trying to do the squad
the way the republicans were able to
nail the squad exactly they're trying to
do that without dramatically it's not
gonna work but you're right hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else